well the University of Maryland is
trying to calm fears that recent mold
problems on campus may be linked to a
virus that caused a student's death 18
year old freshman Olivia paragould I'd
Sunday she had AB no virus which
typically causes respiratory illnesses
the university now says five more
students have illnesses tied to the
virus but insists there's no consistent
connection to mold
Jericka Duncan shows us why Paragons
father believes the school could have
done more Jericka yeah definitely a sad
story considering what we're celebrating
today uh good morning Olivia Perrigo
already suffered from Crohn's disease
and a weakened immune system before
contracting adenovirus her father says
several weeks into the fall semester she
complained of respiratory issues and
visited the campus health center he
believes mold in her dorm room could
have made her even more sick you can't
sleep at night because the pillow is
right next to mold and you're up all
night coughing University of Maryland
freshman Jessica Thompson says she
discovered mold on her shoes and clothes
in her dorm room back in August she
believes the fungus eventually made her
sick we got to go home on the weekends
and we would be totally fine at home and
we would come back and would be
sniffling and coughing and then have
headaches Thompson says she repeatedly
alerted the issue to University
officials who eventually moved her and
more than 500 other students to
temporary housing while the school
worked to clean the dorms they had put
in a dehumidifier and the heat had
finally turned on the mold seemed to go
away but it was a good two and a half
months freshman Olivia para gall died on
Sunday after contracting adenovirus e'en
para gall is her father he says her room
also had mold the University of Maryland
says it learned of the first case of
adenovirus on November 1st this past
Tuesday the school announced there were
a total of six cases including Olivia's
other kids to make sure they don't get
sick I mean apparently there were two
kids sick one when we came forward rate
that was the thirteenth I would have
liked to have had that information and
now there's three markets why we want to
acknowledge that there are cases on
campus we don't necessarily want to stir
up unnecessary angst dr. David McBride
is head of the campus health center what
we've done is we've stepped up our
cleaning efforts we're on high alert
here and we're working to be very
diligent and following up on cases when
students are sick to make sure that they
don't worsen the University of Maryland
says state and local health officials
are investigating the outbreak on campus
meanwhile the CDC says mold can cause
respiratory related symptoms including
wheezing and a stuffy nose adenovirus
began spreading at a New Jersey Health
Center last month eleven children died
in that outbreak and as we were talking
while the story was airing this really
focuses on children or people with a
compromised immune system so you know
it's not like if you get it you're gonna
die but it stinks when you consider the
people who who were impacted by this
you're nonetheless heartbreaking for
their families absolutely thank you
thanks Jerry Ken